le chef conservateur a commencé la
journée en faisant un pied de nez à son
principal adversaire
nous sommes ici à papineau en voyage en
plein coeur de la circonscription du
chef libéral
indochine tente de raviver la sphère
snc-lavalin s'il est élu indochine
promet la tenue d'une enquête publique
l'occasion surtout d' attaquer
l'intégrité de justin trudeau en
l'associant à de la corruption
un trader a réussi à éviter les
conséquences légales de son rôle dans ce
scandale
mais elle est maintenant devant les
tribunaux des peuples
le chef conservateur présenterait aussi
un projet de loi anti obstruction pour
faciliter le travail de la grc
le corps de police fédérale pourrait
s'adresser à la cour suprême pour
obtenir des informations protégées par
la confidentialité du cabinet une idée
rejetée par le camp libéral
c'est très important de protéger le
secret les secrets du cabinet c'est
vraiment ça touche vraiment la capacité
du gouvernement de gouverner un pays
cette offensive conservatrice fait en
sol montréalais
à quelques kilomètres du siège social de
snc lavalin a été très mal reçue par le
bloc québécois
arrêtez de punir des employés innocent
de ce qui en terme d'ingéniérie encore
un fleuron québécois présents dans la
plupart des régions du québec pour faire
du capital politique bas de gamme
atteindrait pour commenter les propos
niant ce chien finaux chef le premier
ministre du québec n'a pas voulu s'en
mêler
lui qui s'était inquiété du sort réservé
au siège social est aux travailleurs de
l'entreprise
indochine lui est persuadé qu aucun
emploi n'est menacé
quoi qu'en dise justin trudeau les
présidents des cci la bla lui même a dit
qu'il ya aucune connotation qui menace
les emplois menacés de déménager
les bus en principal des saints c'est la
wla en attaquant justin trudeau chez lui
à douchy espérait sans doute provoqué le
chef libéral
mais il peut aussi un risque politique
en faisant cette annonce au québec où la
sphère snc-lavalin a soulevé beaucoup
moins d'indignation que dans le reste du
pays
ici louis blouin radio canada montréal